former american league side young winner
in 2018
blake snell who has always been able to
rack up
the strikeouts he's got uh prototype for
pitcher in terms of body 6'4 about 225
pounds in his first season
in san diego and a line drive
base hit for connor joe player
hey you and me both
good for him i mean it's such a
wonderful story but even if if
the story wasn't attached to him you'd
be looking down going you know what he's
putting together good a beast
and not going so an opportunity for two
and trevor beat it you're gonna have to
really hit
a smash at someone if you're trevor
to get doubled up the way he runs even
out of the right side
charlie blackman will try and keep this
bottom of the first going no score
and a walk to blackman so two on now
for mcmahon he struck out more than any
other rocky last year
2-2 and that is on the outside corner
strike three call
blake brought it a little bit closer to
the black and he hit his spot
no runs a hit and two left and one away
in the top of the second with austin
nola coming up
lined into left field a base hit for
nola
first base runner to reach for the
padres it's a base hit for nola
two down in the second inning two
strikeouts for gomber and
hassan kim coming up now for san diego
line to right field and that's a base
hit over to play it is blackman nola's
headed for third base blackman has
trouble with it and nola's gonna be
waved around
the throw will be headed to third and
safe at third base is kim and the padres
take a one-nothing lead
so misplayed by charlie blackman in
right field
and coming around to score as a result
from first base is nola kim ends up at
third base
it's a solid line drive opposite way
two outs noel is running now this is
where bobby dickerson
the third base coach has got to tell
noah hey he bobbled it you got to go
and then kim stay on the bag safely
slides into third
jonathan dazza leads it off for the
rockies
3-2 pitch is a fair ball hit down into
the right field corner
long run for kivlahan plays it well
off the bounce dazzle will hold its
second
it's a leadoff double for the rockies
center fielder
here's josh fuentes did not play in the
opener
josh at 191 does have a couple of homers
and 10 rbis
this is to hit to deep left got a chance
to fly
take a good look you won't see it for
long that was aggressive
and productive two-run home run josh
fuentes
and that ends the homer drop for the
rockies in six games
he ends up throwing a change up and it
just gets
demolished
under control quick to the baseball
just check it out
third homer for fuentes
in his first extra base hit since april
the 17th
two to one rockies
all four and there is the second walk
allowed by snell
wow that's frustrating that's very
frustrating and rhyme
tapia this will get away from nola and
up to second base goes gomber
there's some of that wildness you were
just talking about
the slider that took off
and a ground ball headed towards second
base marcano to first for the out
and on to third base goes gobber with
now two down
gotta figure joe is taking on three and
oh he is and the fastball is inside ball
four
so the walks now stacking up on blake
snell who's throwing more pitches in the
second than he did in the first he's
up over 50 already he has walked three
guys
and now you got a first and third two
out situation with the very
dangerous trevor story coming up
swinging a miss in a pitch way out of
the strike zone but he strikes out
trevor story
and ends his second inning two-run shot
for fuentes it's 2-1 rockies
second hit of the inning here for
colorado and they have runners in first
and second
fastball again and he strikes him out
with it fifth strikeout for snell
two down here in the third inning uno
dos adios
on the ground right at the shortstop kim
he goes the short way
and they force out gaza at second base
to end the inning
no runs couple of hits and two more left
by the rock
fifth inning of the nightcap 2-1 rockies
patrick kivlahan right-handed hitting
outfielder the lefty gomber
kicks and fires strike three called with
a backdoor curveball
this is a great curveball yeah it's an
amazing pitch i mean
it's hitters just give up so andreoli
will come on to pinch it gomber trying
to get andreoli the o2
strike three called backdoor curveball
you liked it once how about again left
on left with grisham
pitch from gomber curveball swang and a
miss he got him
got to have more gombers strikes out the
side
we go to the bottom of the fifth and
here's the pesky
austin nola on the ground to third
and now fuentes will get the out of
first on a good pick by joe
that was really well done by josh great
head he thought for a moment
that machado had gone off the bag enough
that he may be able to get the outs
gonna run out nope don't have the app
but he still had time to get nola at
first
tuku
[Music]
[Applause]
and he prevents the padres from evening
things up
brian o'grady will hit for kivlahan
drives one out towards deep right center
field
off the wall and it'll be played by
hampton to second base
goes o'grady ball gets away it'll be
backed up a one-out wall ball double for
o'grady pinch hit at that
tying run in scoring position for san
diego cadre is 90 feet away from tying
this game with one out
on the ground and through into right
field from third base comes o'grady and
this game is tied
two to two victor caratini drives in the
tying run in the top of the seventh
inning
here's a two and two and cronenworth
reaches for that one hits it in the air
to shallow left tapia coming in he can't
get there it falls down in front of him
carratini's got to hustle into third
it's a force play and he's out
whoa how about the timing of mcmahon
spinning
popping that glove right on the back
tied at two
two outs first and second here there go
the runners the throw to
third and they got him what a throw
by diaz to get grisham
trying to steal third a perfect
throw and the game is still tied
bottom of the eighth two-two game two
down now it's going to take a hit
or something else crazy like a while
joshua fuentes drops his ball
deep center
has completed a great afternoon